♪♪
Cherry:
Sometimes I feel like
I've already seen
Cherry:
everything that's
gonna happen.
♪♪
Cherry:
And it's a nightmare.
(Loud explosion)
Soldier:
Go, go!
(Automatic gunfire)
Soldier:
Go!
♪♪
This is a movie that is based
upon a young man who makes
a really important decision to
Joe Russo:
join the Army during the Iraq
war.
The shock that he experiences in
Iraq is something that he can't
shake for the rest of the film.
(Mirror shattering)
He comes back with undiagnosed
PTSD.
Tom Holland:
It's an invisible affliction.
People see someone with PTSD and
go
"Oh that guy is fine, he came
home and he wasn't injured."
I have this noise in my head.
It'll stop.
Emily:
One day it'll just go quiet.
♪♪
Timothy Wynn:
I came home from Iraq in 2003.
My family, friends, they had no
idea really what was going on
internally with me.
♪♪
When you're coming out of a
combat zone, it is very jarring
to return to the civilian world.
You don't want to talk about it
sometimes, you don't want to go
through it again.
♪♪
Anthony Russo:
The medical system
was unprepared to
Anthony Russo:
help Cherry
with these issues.
How's your pain level?
Nine out of ten.
Have you ever
heard of oxycontin?
They mis-prescribe opioids.
Anthony Russo:
And that turns into a bad
addiction for him.
Anthony Russo:
And that ends up turning into a
life of crime.
(Gunshots)
Get on the ground now!
♪♪
Living with PTSD took me to some
pretty dark places.
♪♪
Timothy Wynn:
I was addicted to drugs and
alcohol and spent a year
Timothy Wynn:
of my life in prison.
Every week there was a younger
version of me walking through
those doors.
♪♪
We have lost family members, we
have others who are struggling
with their sobriety.
♪♪
There is a scale to this that is
terrifying.
(Incoherent screaming)
♪♪
Honorable Patrick Murphy:
There's about 3.3 million
of us that
Honorable Patrick Murphy:
served in Iraq and Afghanistan.
And there still are far too many
that do fall thru the cracks.
Honorable Patrick Murphy:
Sometimes they give up hope.
That's why it's important to
tell these stories.
♪♪
A movie like Cherry helps all of
us to understand that it's okay
to reach out for help.
Jimmy Butler:
And we, as a country, can begin
this healing process together.
♪♪
You're it for me.
I feel the same way.
Cherry represents the
possibility of a bright future.
♪♪
I believe this film is gonna
help people, and get the
struggle out to the masses.
They showed the grit of not just
combat, but coming back on the
other side.
♪♪
There are so new many therapies
that are out there, it's gonna
be different
for all of us, we have to
understand that.
♪♪
Jimmy Butler:
But hope is a mandatory.
We have to do everything we can
to make sure that we leave
no-one behind.
We owe it to the ones that did
not come back to live a happy
and healthy life.
♪♪
Tom Holland:
The service men and women here
today really are unparalleled
and we're indebted to them in
every way.
♪♪
Cherry:
Sometimes I feel like I've
already seen
Cherry:
everything that's
gonna happen.
♪♪
Cherry:
But for the first time, it
didn't scare me.
♪♪